when you have youth smashing glass and
stealing two million dollars worth of
stuff
that's a sign
that the glue holding our society is
definitely definitely weakening
[Music]
hello my name is pastor corey brooks i'm
coming to you from the south side of
chicago and i'm on the rooftop where i'm
living in this tent for 100 days that's
right 100 days can you believe that
in the winter in the windy city
why am i doing it i'm trying to bring
about awareness to crime that is going
on every single day
and also specifically to raise funds to
build a community center
in a neighborhood that desperately needs
it
every day i'm going to be coming to you
with rooftop revelations
thanks to fox giving me this platform
i'm going to share with you some
thoughts
from the south side of chicago from this
rooftop
today i want to talk about something
that i woke up to that just startled me
it's this thing called
smash and grab it's where these kids
get together and they run into
department stores or
other stores that have any type of
material that's worth something
of value they smash the glass and they
take it
well
when you have youth
smashing glass and stealing two million
dollars worth of stuff
that's a sign
that the glue holding our society is
definitely definitely weakening
it's a sign of what i want to call
and eli still calls
bad faith
bad faith means one doesn't have faith
in society
in bad faith
uh the world
uh they don't trust it anymore
it's it's every man
every person for themselves
and that's what we're seeing in our
youth
especially here in chicago
so the question is
where did this glue begin
to
unravel where did it begin to
weaken
does it begin in the hole
does it begin with poor educational
systems
or
does it begin with
government dependency
well at this point
we can debate where the problem was
created
but we're beyond debates right now
we know the glue holding society has
weakened to the point
that we're seeing these ridiculous
headlines
every day about crime
and all i know
is that we need to do
our very best
to restore the good faith in our society
with good faith is to give our youth
something to to care about to believe in
and the
problem right now
is that our kids have nothing
to believe in
they see failure everywhere
that's why we at project hood are trying
to raise money to build this community
center
it's a way of showing these kids
who didn't choose to be born here
that there is definitely
definitely a better life
that society cares about them that their
neighbors care about them that their
families
care about them
with that good faith
we can restore the goodwill and respect
in our society
we simply have no other choice or the
headlines are going to get worse
so i'm going to take you on this journey
with me because
my goal
is to restore that good faith
thank you for joining me tonight with my
rooftop revelations
i'll see you tomorrow
you